benvenuti al grande fratello mi scoppia
sempre di più il cuore
mi scoppissima mi super scoppia voi non
avete idea che emozione siamo di nuovo
qua dopo un anno siamo pronti io sono
pronta a voi siete pronti e quindi direi
di collegarci subito immediatamente con
la piscina della casa dove incontreremo
il primo conc no vabbè no vabbè cristiano
cristiano mi senti é calda dico é calda
l'acqua cristiano cristiano niente
cristiano non ci sente quindi direi di
non perdere tempo e collegarci con la
passerella dove c'è la seconda nostra
opinionista del cuore sto parlando di
iva zanicchi amore yuhuu grazie grazie
ragazzi c'è un entusiasmo fantastico incredibile
bene dopo aver presentato i nostri
opinionisti supertop direi di passare
subito alla presentazione alla clip del
primo concorrente sono ivana icardi
ho 23 anni sono argentina mi dispiace
avere questa voce che sembro loredana
bertré sono la sorella de mauro icardi
che è un grande giocatore e gioca
nell'inter el rapporto con mio fratello si è
rovinato dal momento che c'è una persona
nella sua vita che non mi convince esta
con questa moglie che sino fosse
calciatore mai starebbe con lui sono
arrabbiata delusa
finalmente sono arrivati in studio i
miei due opinionisti che ho voluto
tantissimo con me sto parlando di
cristiano malgioglio e iva zanicchi
ciao a tutti buonasera sono molto emozionato sai barbara buonasera grazie
ciao barbara ciao amore
no vabbè cristiano ma ma ce le hai le
mutandine
bè che c'è non hai mai visto un uomo
con il kilt dai cristiano diccelo che cosa hai li sotto
frutta e verdura tesoro vieni a vedere
dai dai che te lo faccio vedere
lasciamo perdere cristiano e passiamo
alla seconda clip del secondo
concorrente che tra l'altro ti vuole
molto bene cristiano sa di chi sto
parlando
sto parlando di lui il ciclone lemme al
grande fratello
tuoni fulmini tempeste dopo di me la casa
non sarà più la stessa cosa siete
ciccioni o diversamente secchi il genio é
in arrivo a presto
ci mancava solo lui l'anno scorso
chi c'era come si chiamava quella lí la
spagnola
aida eh quest'anno c'è lui ma si
cristiano vedrai che diventerete ottimi
amici
passiamo subito al terzo concorrente
sono salentina vignali ho 27 anni sono nata a rimini ma vivo a roma nella vita sono una
modella un'influencer una cestista guarda
il bottone so grassa mortacci tua i miei amici
mi chiamano vignalona per ovvie ragioni
fisiche
quindi state molto attenti sono stata
fidanzata cinque anni e mezzo e ci avevo
pure creduto se lui bussasse alla casa
del grande fratello rimarrebbe fuori e
sotto la pioggia con un piccione che li
caga in testa e adesso è arrivato il
momento di un ragazzo che io adoro ha
una voce pazzesca e sono sicura che
tutti voi vi ricorderete di lui
ciao mi chiamo christian ho 23 anni
e vengo da palermo il canto é una passione
che ho da quando avevo 5 anni
cantavo con i telecomandi in mano
fuori dal balcone i vicini di casa
mi urlavano di smettere
poi è arrivato io canto che è stato il
mio grandissimo trampolino di lancio ho
un caratterino un pó spigoloso se
vengo stuzzicato diventa una vipera
sicuramente l'immagine dell'angioletto
di io canto morirà proprio andrà nel
dimenticatoio
nel cesso e dopo il nostro christian
parliamo di una donna di una ragazza che
ha da poco voltato pagina
sto parlando di lei ciao sono mila ho 31
anni e faccio la modella sono nata e
cresciuta in marocco fino all'età di 12
anni
poi mi sono trasferita in italia con mio
papà forse mi avrete già vista in
giornali o tv perché ero fidanzata con
alex belli noi sognavamo una famiglia di
sposarci avere figli
e invece mi ha tradito oggi alex è
ancora fidanzato con quella con cui mi
ha tradito chi è una donna senza
identità
entro nella casa del grande fratello con
il cuore libero ma ancora diciamo un
pochino spezzato e lo sto cucendo
piano concluderei questa
carrellata dei nostri concorrenti del
grande fratello 16 con un personaggio
totalmente fuori dalle righe
e proprio per questo motivo io lo adoro
che si chiama enrico contarin grande
fratello quando ci sei io ci sono
ciao sono enrico contarin ho 26 anni sono
di bessega lavoro nell'azienda di
famiglia per 19 anni ero un madrelingua
veneto parlavo veneto con tutti poi ho
fatto la valigia direzione capoluogo
lombardo e mi sono iscritto
all'università
nessuno si aspettava che un tosetto come mi
ciapasse due lauree una la ciapan
in tanti ma do tutto quello che go da fare
xe lavorare vendere borse e far quel che
mi dixe mio papà eccoci purtroppo
arrivati al termine di questa prima
meravigliosa puntata prima di salutarvi
ci terrei anche a salutare i nostri due
opinionisti top cristiano
amore e iva ciao a tutti grazie grazie e
ciao amore
se volete una seconda puntata della
parodia del grande fratello 16 fatemelo
sapere qui sotto mi raccomando se non lo
avete ancora fatto mi raccomando
iscrivetevi al canale di marina perché è
super top io la adoro e seguitela su
tutti gli altri social facebook tik tok
e instagram
non mi resta che dire una cosa che non
dico mai col cuore perché nel mio cuore
ci sono prima i miei figli ma subito dopo ci siete voi col cuore col cuore adoro